matpat did an oopsie logan paul dierden
oopsie pokeyman didn't oopsie gillette
did a new proceeded soldier boy didn't
oopsie we have so many freaking oopsies
I am freaking out this has never
happened before on peer news my name is
Gloria Borger and welcome to peel news
the most respected most trusted and
highest-quality video camera footage
production news source I'm not supposed
to flirt with my audience but you look
really great today smash like let's get
into the oopsies but Felix why don't you
per reported positive if it's it's
Gloria it is our first oopsie comes from
none other than logan paul logan paul
did an oopsie what this is so
disappointed PT pi just wore love and
Paul's merch
I bet he's furious right now if next
Logan Paul scandal is his worst yet if
you thought the suicide course that was
bad just wait till you hear how does
Logan pool still have a career after
this
I thought Japan Forrest was as bad as
against but apparently not I'm disgusted
I didn't think Logan Poole could get any
worse after Japan okay so what did Logan
Paul actually do let's check it out why
don't you say this omits male-only March
we're gonna attempt to go gay for just
one more one and then swing and I go
back oh my god I stuck my neck out for
you Logan
Paul I mean PewDiePie what the Frick man
I had your back and this is how you
repay PewDiePie I'm going to support
Logan Paul I think he's getting better
Logan Paul literally the next day I'm
gonna pretend to be gay for a month pink
am ia joke to you Logan Paul LP is that
what this is about
can't you tell I'm shaking and crying
right now how could you say this Logan
Paul would never say this okay
now I get kind of why people are upset
yes being homosexual is not a choice but
I also think that's not what he was
saying
it's like saying the people that say hey
no p-chan
ah you can't say that you're teaching
young kids not to pee and that's really
harmful I don't know man male only marge
was that it it's such a stupid joke like
is that really worth getting that upset
about personally I don't think so
so I guess you can say I feel a maverick
where's my maverick merch I threw it
away thinking I would never wear it
again ah damn it I didn't I do think
it's interesting though because now
Logan Paul has a podcast of out of all
things and he's under such a magnifying
glass that even small stuff like this
will 100% blow up in his face and if
anything is podcasts probably just
benefit from it anyway like I don't even
know we had one so that's how the works
just stop getting pissed off at things
if you really hate it that much just
stop talking about it if you really feel
like you want to be offended or angry
about something which I can understand
we live in a dark place well then I have
the story for you this is the most
upsetting news story of all time here on
P news a record holder and I'm not
supposed to give my opinion or that's a
scientific fact beloved cat fired from
his job at local public library this is
a nerd I am not supposed browser his
name is browser that's the beloved cat
that has been a fixture of the local
library for six years recently lost his
job he has children read on June 14 the
City Council the City Council now it's a
time for us to rise up I don't care
about T series anymore this is the issue
I will stand for fighting to death for
oh wait beloved cat will keep its job at
the local library after international
backlash we did it we did a good job
guys give yourself a pat on the back we
did a change in the positive world today
huh who says this channel is all about
drama
I cover important news stories here and
that's not my opinion that's a
straight-up hey Knicks oopsie mad pad
didn't oopsy doopsy oversee oopsy doopsy
the map I was training on Twitter a few
days ago why did he do
did he tell more lives about how pretty
pie success went so mad pan went live on
his channel and he played this game
called heart bound the game looks very
similar to hundred tales so Madge had
decided hey I'm gonna title this
undertale surprise big Joe it's it'll
mean making charitable face alright
let's see well nothing wrong with this
youyou say but well no apparently the
dev of the game was watching the
developer of heart bound and he made a
comment that the title of the video was
the next undertale game is here there
was no link to heart bound but there
were links to his other undertale videos
there was a bunch of hashtags and tags
for undertale to heavily promote
undertale when he's like well my game is
hard man why are you so obsessed with
undertale and he called him out on
twitter saying i'm pretty to this point
of here so is our community your reasons
that I became across as undertale
clickbait instead of being about heart
BAM you never link to our game and you
got our studio name wrong as well and
Matt Rhett Pat replied with I'm sorry to
hear you're disappointed in our recent
playthrough of hardbound but what you
see there's a twist coming up here boys
not girls but what do you see as
disrespectful I would argue it's the
opposite
let me explain first I don't review the
thumbnails tags in description someone
else does okay I don't care that said
their goal is to make live streams as
searchable as possible and for games
with limited search ability that's
important as it gets them the audience
and attention they deserve basically
you're gamers not interesting in a
hardbound
I don't know what to tell you man your
game is great and by relating it to
something similar that our audience
already knows and enjoys we're hoping to
introduce them to it they might not have
checked it out if it left with Cyril
context
that's the rationale hopefully makes it
so in a way from a youtuber perspective
I understand this this is what youtubers
do I mean when people play Delta rune
which wasn't really undertale sequel
toby fox himself said it you know it's
not undertale - but people still tagged
it or title is as undertale - because
that will get people's attention you
know they're curious about it undertale
- is here on they'll take to do it
better
undertale youtuber do this - up here in
the search for example you search on
something oh
undertale in the title that's more
likely to show up unless you're
pewdiepie he's a goddamn [ __ ] he
doesn't know how to title list
god dammit why did I not think of this
now it's fine I get hit mad PES
rationale of 100% because technically it
will bring him more attention to heart
bound if he associates it with undertale
and his game already looks very similar
to undertale so why shouldn't he I mean
I'm actually you know despite the the
delivering of what he's saying I
understand his message and I actually
agree with it however he then finishes
off with that for some goddamn reason
saying that regarding links we don't
tend to link back to the games we're
playing that's not an intentional slide
on you it's just rarely something we do
for a games that aren't fan made or free
so basically no I'm not gonna link to
your game why this I don't understand
whatsoever all you have to do is link to
the game how is that too much to ask for
someone is it calling you out on Twitter
being like dude what the hell are you
doing just link to the game no why why
matpat I'm shaking and crying right now
map I would never do this you're
broadcasting their game the minimum
thing you could do is at least link to
the game I get it I don't like putting
the actual name of the game in the title
as well because I know people don't
click on my videos for what the game is
so there's really no reason for me to do
that and I know from experience in the
that's affect as well if people enjoy
the video they know what game I'm
playing so I'm like well if they want to
get the game surely they will buy it but
if someone requests you to link the game
why can't you just do it now I think I
know the reason why which I haven't seen
anyone else discuss but basically the
way the YouTube algorithm works is that
if you link in your video to something
that goes outside of the platform the
algorithm doesn't like that they want
you to stay on YouTube so if if they
link to other games in their videos and
people click off the site then that's
bad for that video and it's not gonna
get recommended and get as much views
that's mostly I'm not saying that's the
definite reason why but I know that math
hat is very savvy with these kind of
things and that's most likely why he
chose not to link in the description
still just link the goddamn game now the
craziest part of this was that Toby Fox
the creator of undertale came in out of
nowhere flapped his dick on the table
and said you should link to any game you
play creators need all the help they can
get and think carefully if you're
missing your audience with how you
present your videos you went too far in
this time
then mad Pat went completely 180 and
said sorry I mean no disrespect
apologies are one thing but actions are
another now I will link all of it and I
mean it's a really any reason to be mad
at this point I mean he's changing his
methods to something positive and I
think you know you did wrong you do the
right thing what else can you ask for I
think it's fair to say at least then
it's kind of weird how he blatantly said
no up until the point where a bigger
creator calls you out on and basically
that's when you realize oh oh and maybe
I shouldn't do this
oh okay ah damn I messed up now pirate
software the developer is saying it
would really cool if everyone stopped
attacking my pad on our behalf we had an
issue he fix it I thanked him for the
fix everyone went home happy and the
progress was made in our slice of the
Internet so the whole thing is settled
there's really no reason to
talk about this I just wanted to give
some further insight and I do think it's
interesting as well with the whole
linking thing I think we as youtubers
need to be better and myself included
and with respecting the footage that is
giving us the content I think that's the
least we can do at least which brings us
to
oopsie number three that's right we got
two more boys yeah
pokey main so I brought a pokey man in
one of my recent videos called stop
doing this basically saying stop
copyright videos to idiots you're making
everything worse people abusing the
copyright system which is already so
broken ace is bad for everyone that was
my point on the video so I called out a
couple examples and pokeyman was one of
them and I would have to say I think
pokey man's example was the least
harmful one and I was almost arguing in
her favor but then I didn't know this
but apparently someone else called her
out at the same time made a video called
the dark side of pokey Maine
so when Pokemon made a response to my
video and the other video
well people weren't happy about it it
has almost as many likes as dislikes
people who are very angry and personally
I didn't understand why people were mad
at all I just thought well she addressed
the points what else can she do really
that's not pewdiepie that's Gloria
Borger you Draghi bang Jesus Christ so I
wanted to break down why are people
pissed off so in a way I can understand
why you want to take down this video
because this selected thing blows up and
becomes even bigger the re-upload of the
Twitter beef wasn't transformative
content so I was able to get it taken
down through my MCN but again PewDiePie
was in the right by saying but the
problem here is that you're just drawing
more attention to it trying to like hide
all that drama only ended up bringing
more attention to it again in the moment
I was just doing that because I thought
it was something that would calm down
all the drama but I think the video was
recorded within 24 hours and they asked
if I wanted to get it taken down again
but I just said that it was fine to
leave it okay so basically Pokemon took
down a video that was a Twitter beef
between her and King star
my point in the video was well I get
that this looks bad for you and I
understand why you want to take it down
but you're just gonna draw more
attention to it anyway which is has
clearly done as well I mean this whole
thing is crazy how much it blew up over
something so small now people were I
think rightfully saying that why should
you take down videos that you deem are
not transformative when you have content
yourself that is arguably not
transformative at all what gives you the
right to strike out the Condor creators
when you do the exact same thing I think
that's the main issue that bothers a lot
of people I mean she even put on one one
of my videos and I don't know went to
the bathroom or something just where I
think great I get it that is different
boards and streamers as well obviously
if you stream for hours and hours every
single day to have all of that original
content yes it's gonna be some of it
that isn't I get that I'm personally not
mad about it but I still think you know
the same argument still applies what
gives you the right to strike other
people if you're doing the same thing
basically now the other reason why
people were upset was because she had
discovered that someone else had
reordered her content and kind of put
heavily sexualized titles and thumbnails
around it 700,000 views yeah so this is
where you get your 550 check from huh no
I don't thank you for monetization
actually so it's just do it for fun okay
so this guy that she's talking to on
discord is someone that like I said
reuploads her content and other
youtubers as well
some of them gets a lot of you some of
them get no traction at all but they're
not monetized essentially so I don't
know
she made a response about this whole
thing saying basically that I will
sometimes take down videos when it's a
straight re-upload of my stream and when
it's like a gross and misleading title I
also take those down because my mom
really doesn't like seeing them on
YouTube searches sorry mom
so basically she doesn't like they have
bad titles around there which again I
can understand but same argument again
why so much time to go to the top of
some port 9 then just right click and
save all of the mouse and then just like
put them all into Premiere and then just
like export it I'm so sorry
okay let's be real here reuploading
fortnight compilation clips to monetize
that content it's kind of the lowest
form of making money on YouTube I mean
let's get really that if I had to think
of the easiest way to make money with no
personality on YouTube I would literally
just reupload streamers highlights like
that seems to me like the easiest way to
just make a quick buck I'm not saying
that doesn't take any effort but it's
still so I understand why she said this
but a lot of people seem really upset
like oh that she was being really mean
to this guy or whatever and that she
showed his Instagram on the stream as
well as a way that to attack him who
some people the former you started on
yesterday and I agree she should never
pull up his instrument stream that's a
bad mood regardless if she was making
fun of him or not he even said himself
that people found his Instagram just
from talking to him so people were bound
to found it anyway but you know it
doesn't look good I'm so bored by this
now we know why people are upset I guess
maybe I missed something I don't know
I think if Pokemon just had reached out
to guy who did the keemstar video first
and said hey would you mind removing
this video then this whole thing would
have been avoided a lot of people don't
really know what a copyright claim
entails
it's basically forcing you to go to
court if someone fights it you have to
it is a legal move to make so a lot of
people put up a copyright
to take down a video they they're not
aware of what they're actually
initiating so I take that request I
think would be a great solution to a lot
of these issues I'm gonna bring it up to
YouTube so hopefully I don't know if
they agree or not but that's it at the
end of the day I don't care this is such
a boring drama Jesus Christ meme review
oh we have two more oopsies how is this
oh my god
Jesus Christ let's just jump into it
guys we're almost there
Soulja Boy did an oopsie again you'd
think after Nintendo crackdown on Soulja
Boy he would stop but no soldier boys
like okay well then Sony it's Sony time
everybody Soulja Boy announces a new
sketchy console which looks identical to
a PlayStation Vita and why why should
you pay $33 for a product when you can
buy the exact same problem as literally
the places Vita when you can buy the
exact same product called soldier game
and it's $99.99 oh that's a great price
why pay a third of the price when you
can play pay way more look it's $200
discount what a great deal what is even
what is a PlayStation Vita go for oh my
god he sells it at the same price why
buy a real pro what Soulja Boy also
announced this soldier board what's next
when are we seeing the soldier condoms
come on soldier boy I thought you were
an entrepreneur finally we did it that
final oopsy Gillette the best a man can
get or is it
Gillette faces backlash and boycott over
me to advert so she let upload a short
film called we believe the best man can
be and it's safe to say that a lot of
people didn't like this video it's right
now sitting on 50 mm dislikes and only a
thousand likes 8.5 I really really
appreciate the Guardians title on this
it doesn't show any bias at all
Gillette hashtag me to add on toxic
masculinity gets praised and abuse that
seems like such a fair assessment you
know no it doesn't i liked how they
didn't call it criticism it's just abuse
everyone that dislikes this video abuse
this poor brand this poor g like
multi-million dollar brand is getting
abuse it sad is it a billion dollar
brand i wouldn't surprise me
refuse even love criticizing it Jesus
Christ they're so desperate in the
comments as well deleting a bunch of
comments from the video they even pinned
a comment saying best commercials ever
oh my god best commercial ever
just give up Sheila you made a video ok
let's go through it it hasn't even
started in the first thing bullying hey
did you guys know only men bully that's
the only thing that happens oxic
masculinity everyone god damn it guys no
one likes men's anymore and we have a
men heavily man oriented brand we're
gonna have to rebrand the whole thing as
command toxic masculinity everyone who
doesn't like to have their Mortal
Kombat's defined to them by a shaving
company maybe I shouldn't be such an
[ __ ] to women you know that Gillette
had really swayed my mind on things it
really opened my my eyes to the issues
oh look they're bullying guys bully did
you know that guys bully people Hydra
women never bully anyone has been going
on far too long
[Music]
we can't laugh at all
what I actually think she's trying to
say making the same old excuses boys
can't fight each other boys can't
wrestle with each other and there will
be no going back
because we we believe in the best in men
men need to hold other men accountable
come on
I don't understand what is the context
here maybe I'm part of the problem I
don't get what the issue here is so
they're filming something and he's
saying smile sweetie and this guy is
like yo yo come on man what's the
context and we're just gonna assume then
the act what's happening not cool man
never approach our whamon not cool man
the right way yeah not cool man this guy
is like dude how could he how dare you
in ways big and small
[Music]
but some is not enough we treat each
other again
because the boys watching today
we'll be the men of tomorrow watching
this video it doesn't piss me off
I don't really care that much I just
think it's very it's cringe-worthy
that's what it is
why is Gillette trying to tell me or
everyone that guys are a problem they're
literally putting all guys that are
problematic in that same category why
not focus on something positive instead
a positive example the show caves men
that actually do something good if you
wanna have an inspiring message instead
of something that says shame on everyone
you know at the end of the day
Gillette's goal is to sell products you
know their motivation behind this video
was to do exactly just that that doesn't
mean that's necessarily is bad but at
the same time again it's so cringy that
they're trying to put up this message to
sell more products it blows my mind that
they thought this was an actual good
idea there's a lot of constructive
comments in in there someone actually
commented my wife's son loved this thank
you happy to hear you enjoyed it and
thank you for watching is that real
that's great that's it for pears guys I
hope you enjoyed this episode smash like
if you enjoyed and as always smash
subscribe
he series it's literally right around
the corner full-on panic mode thank you
check out new merch and I see you guys
tomorrow
bye
[Music]